welcome to annex talk
we're going to have Philippians talking
about ASD I the synchronous server get
to our interface so please give him a
nice round of applause thank you it's
it's um do you hear me yeah so I'm going
to introduce ASCII today Lee
asynchronous survey gateway interface
but just to get an idea how many people
already know what ASCII is oh it's a few
goods so hopefully by the end of this
talk you have a very good idea of what
ask is if it's a good talk and yeah but
before I get into that just a little
about me if you want to follow along
with the slides locally you can find
them on pgf you can also find me as PJ
Jones don't get blab github and medium
it's slightly more complicated on
Twitter there's an extra D somebody
outside the name but there we are so I'm
going to introduce ASCII but to do that
I'm going to step back and introduce
whiskey I suspect most of the people in
this will in this room know what whiskey
is but if you don't and you've done any
web stuff in Python you almost certainly
used it I explain what it is if you
don't know but to go back to when whisky
was introduced in 2003 quite a time ago
now there was quite a an ecosystem of
Python web servers already such as oak
exe web where etc now one of the issues
at the time was that these these
frameworks differ in their API and their
functionality but they're all very
distinct you couldn't take parts of
twisted and use it with soap at least as
I understood at the time so you've got
to make a choice you're gonna use one or
the other and this kind of feeds
directly in to the motivation for whisky
at the time which I'll just read out cuz
I figured like summarizes it very
succinctly which is Python currently
boasts a wide variety of web application
frameworks such as soap quixote web
where skunk where PSO and twisted web if
i've pronounced the wall right this wide
variety of choices can be problem for
new Python users because generally
speaking their choice of web framework
will limit their choice of usable web
servers and vice versa and so this was
seen in in 2003
and the pep free free free if you want
to read it get about to deduce whiskey
and what whiskey is is a standard
interface that allows you to separate
the server code which is mostly about
parsing I understand the HTTP something
at that time from the application code
which is mostly about how you kind of
route and couple the your business logic
into your web server and whisky which
stands for the webserver gateway
interface is quite simple in principle
what you have to do is your application
is define it as a callable that takes
two arguments the first argument environ
describes the request and the
environment that they serve all the
frameworks run again and the second
argument start response is a callable
which you called to start the response
in this case with the status and some
headers and then you return or yield the
body so it's quite simply defined and
that allowed the servers which again is
mostly a belt passed and understand the
HTTP to be separated from the frame
which is more about the API and how it's
used so I think it's fair to say that
whisky has been a really great success
for Python there's a lot of whisky
frameworks they differ in terms of River
you and I go full batches included like
Django also very minimal like flask or
bottle and everything in between and so
you've got real choice there in what
kind of API you want to use and just as
a note here because whisky sounds a lot
like whisky a lot of them are named
after receptacles like bottle and flask
and Falcon cetera so it's not only serve
I realized recently on the other side
there's the whisky service I think there
are less of these because it's more
defined it's more constrained by the
protocols but there are free big ones I
know after unicorn you whiskey and
Apache I think the main kind of feature
you'd go for here is how they manage
concurrency that's sort of that's what
you're gonna really care about when
choosing these but again it's given
users of and Python the Python ecosystem
a lot of choice which is the great thing
about whisky so over the roughly 15
years maybe a bit more that whiskies
been about it started to show its age
and I think this is mostly because of
changes
in the kind of web systems around it
rather than whiskey itself
so of all the limitations the first one
I'll mention is that it has no official
way to deal with WebSockets in fact as
you saw that callable it's a request
response cycle expects you to return a
response and be done whereas of course
with WebSockets that connection is going
to stay up and you're just going to send
messages back and forth now there is an
unofficial workaround which is almost a
wrapper around the socket but it depends
again on what concurrency framework
you're using so it's not standardized
for the same reason it doesn't really
say much about h-2b - in terms of
concurrency you can use HTTP - it's just
a request response cycle but you've got
to decide on top of it how you're gonna
make it concurrent because h-2b - is
concurrent you can't get away from it
carrying arm you can't use the asynch
and await keywords they've only recently
been introduced that I think this is
more than Factory async code and Cinco
doesn't really work well together you
can't really use it with with risky
service because the event loops if you
have them fight each other and finally
yeah I haven't mentioned it here but the
request body you may want to stream it
into your server so you might want to
get it in chunks and there's some
support for that convenient whiskey but
generally speaking the whiskey standard
is defined that you get the whole body
and then you pass it into the collar
ball in the environment so you've got a
the service gotta have it all before it
can call your application so these
limitations I think of what started to
motivate async web frameworks which has
been quite an explosion of in the last
few years and I think the first one that
came about was HTTP which I've shown a
little example here so you can see it
meets a lot of these these desires these
limitations first you can use the async
await keywords you can awake the DB call
you can see there secondly although it's
not shown here it does do WebSockets as
well you can stream the request body and
although a HTTP doesn't say anything
about HTTP - it may do in the future and
some earlier frameworks and servers I'm
going to talk about in a minute do
so looking at where we are today it I
would say it's quite similar to where we
were or where the community was in 2003
there's quite a few async frameworks and
these logos are a HTTP blacksheep sanic
jet pronto and vibora so some of them I
don't think Joe pronto vibora maintained
anymore but all of these have kind of
made a name in there in the ecosystem
mostly because in the in these cases
just how better performance they provide
which I'll come to later but that's kind
of what's made people excited alongside
these features but especially for these
frameworks because you can't use them to
ever you can't mix and match I think
they make for the perfect motivation for
a ski and if I talk about original
motivation for whisky and change it very
slightly and say that Python currently
boasts a wide variety of async web
frameworks such as a HTTP sanic black
sheep jump onto an vibora this variety
of choices can be a problem for new
Python users because generally speaking
their choice of wave framework will
limit their choice of usable web servers
and vice versa I think this goes beyond
just new
- users as well I think this is a
limitation to all of us I think this is
a good motivation to want a new standard
to come about that works in the
asynchronous world and that standard I
hope to convince you should be a ski and
a ski stands for asynchronous server
gateway interface I think it's so named
to make the parallels to whiskey and
I'll try and as we go into this I'll try
and say what my involvement is it's been
a small part but I try and say where my
biases come through but basky itself is
again about defining your application as
a callable but in this case it's a
carotene function so it's async by by
default and this time the color ball
takes free arguments the scope which is
very similar to the environ it tells you
about the connection in this case
because it's not necessarily just a HTTP
request and there's two extra color
balls are receiving a sent to you as an
application have to receive messages
from the server and then send them back
and you can see in this an example
they're all asynchronous so it all works
and they can
framework and the link there you can
find in the slides I'll just go to
that's the specification as it's written
out so to give you an example of what it
looks like
so the whiskey example I showed earlier
words simply respond with a 200 response
we have a very short body that just says
hello world
- whatever request it got as with this
piece of code here so the big
differences are that you have to now
check this a HTTP request so you're not
responding to a WebSockets a Weaver
response because it wouldn't make any
sense and then much like with whisky you
start by sending the response
information the status in the headers so
you start the response and then you
stream or send off the the body and in
this case it's just hello world so it's
quite simple so this I think is roughly
the same as the whiskey one you saw a
few minutes ago so I'm going to go into
more detail now about what ask is and
all the different parts of it thanks but
just to give you an idea of the
development of it so that ski came about
through I think the Django's channel's
development which was I think the
ultimate aim of this is to make Django
async and the first version of ASCII
separated the server and the application
by process was quite complicated and you
can thankfully just ignore it so if you
do manage to find anything that
references sq1
you can just forget about it then
there's a skew to which and ask you free
which are very similar there they're
roughly the same it's just ASCII freeze
a bit simpler and cleaned up and I'm
only going to talk about ASCII free but
if you come across a ski - basically
anything that supports a ski free will
probably support us q2 at this time so
there we are ok so I'm going to go into
a bit of detail to get you hopefully
really know how a ski works so the first
thing that callable gets as an
application is the scope and the scope
is telling you about the connection and
for a HTTP request that's going to tell
you about the HTTP request so every us
key message has a type so this type use
HTTP it's going to have a HTTP version
and then it's going to define the
request so that's the method the scheme
the path the crew string and the headers
and then a little bit about the
connection itself the client address and
the server address and then a bit about
the environment which is the
path so this is what you get in the
scope and this is this is pretty much it
and it's it's very similar to the
whiskey and violin so you as an
application get sent this when that
client connects to the server then you
as an application are going to wait for
messages off the server to know what you
want to do so what you're likely to
receive from the server to begin with is
a message that says that there's a HTTP
request body coming through and in this
case to demonstrate streaming the first
message you get is just says hello but
then it's telling you there's more body
expected so you're probably has an
application you're going to expect the
next message to come from the server to
be something similar until you've ran
out of body in this case you get the
final part world and then tells you
there's no more body coming so now you
as an application can start sending your
response so the first thing you're going
to send is the basic information about
the response the status and the headers
and then you'll Stream out the body in
this case because I ran out of slide
space it's just one message which is
just hi and so you send it off and then
the clients going to disconnect from the
server most likely and so you receive
from the server and that's happened a
disconnect message and 4hb message this
is basically all you need to get right
for ascii to have a ASCII application
run so moving on to WebSockets so it's
all a cigarettes like I said earlier it
supports HPT and WebSockets so we have a
WebSocket connection the scope is a
little bit different this time first it
says it's a WebSocket connection in the
type the connection information similar
you get told the scheme the path we're
stirring at headers but you also get
told the sub protocols which matter for
the connection a little bit about the
connection the client server addresses
and then finally the root path so again
when a a client connects to the server
you get called with this scope and again
you as an application they're going to
expect some messages off the server and
then going to respond to them and the
first thing you need to do as a
WebSocket is decide that you want to
accept that connection and turn it into
a fully WebSocket connection so you send
this back to the server so now it is a
WebSocket connection
you perhaps will soon receive a bytes
frame from the client through the server
or maybe a text frame so you can get
both for these and you can send back any
frame you want at any time as well and
then again most like we've history
repeat you've got to decide when you
want to close the connection so you can
send a close back and then once it's
closed you get told that it's this big
clients disconnected from the server so
again this is roughly all you need for
ASCII application so there's one more
part of ASCII that matters is a kind of
protocol stage and this is the one the
part where I start to have been more
involved in ASCII so this is more of my
bus but one of the issues I found with
whisky and so you can't really decide
that you need to prepare something
before the service should start
receiving requests so a good example of
this is if you're going to connect to a
database you probably want to create a
connection pool and create that before
you receive a single request otherwise
it's just going to add latency it's a
very first request if you use flask you
probably already get this with the
before first wish risk quest so the
ASCII lifespan protocol allows the
server to send to you that it's ready so
it sends you as a lifespan startup and
you as an application set up and you
send back to the server that you're
ready when you say startup completes and
from that point arm the server can start
accepting connections so if you're if
you've got say a load balance tanks set
of servers you could just roll them over
easier equally when you're shutting down
gracefully there's the is the opposite
on shutdown so that's life span then
there are two extensions to ASCII both
of which I've been quite involved with
the first of which is serverpush so for
H to be two connections you can decide
as a server you want to push your
response to the client before the client
asks for it you often want to do this
when you know the clients going to
request of an a good example being if
the clients requested he's HTML file
they're probably going to ask for the
CSS and JavaScript next to send it to
the client before they ask and save a
bit of latency so that's the serverpush
so as an application you simply look for
the scope and look to see if they
got an extension that says it allows
serverpush and then you could send this
message to the server seg server push
this to the client nanostick yeah the
next extension is to be able to send a
different response when a WebSocket
connection request is made
so when WebSockets are kind of made or
the connections are attempted it starts
with a HTTP message that asks for an
upgrade
now most libraries will allow you to
accept that message or just close the
connection if you don't want to so what
this extension allows you to do is
instead say I want to reject the upgrade
will be this particular message so you
can be a bit more formative maybe say
that they don't have the right
credentials or that the request is badly
formed or something like that so it's
again you just need to lock in the
extensions and if you're wondering about
the empty dictionary that's just so
there's extra options it's not a typo
but so you look for this extension and
then you can send messages back to the
server like you would for HTTP message
only their prefix now with WebSocket so
it's exactly the same you just send back
an HTTP response so that in a bit of a
rush is it's pretty much the whole ASCII
spec and you can go read the details for
the exact but that's pretty much all of
it so much like whiskey I think this is
start to have a really good effect on
the community like there are a lot of s
keyframe which start to exist now so
just to name a few this court fast api
responder starlet and django channels I
think Django itself who's becoming a sig
I know a bit less than this but it looks
like it probably will
my bias here is I work on court so
courts very flushed like as are most of
these so in terms of the ASCII features
I've just talked about there's there's a
strong bias here because the extensions
are my interest so I've written them but
basically all of them work for the basic
ASCII spec so you go use any of these
with the ascii service and you'll have a
good time looking at the ascii service
as far as I know this currently four or
four main ones
so there's hyper core and you recall and
Daphne and
I'm gone again I've got a bias here cuz
I write hyper core but in terms of the
other son manga is a service one if
you're interested in that I think
Daphne's very popular in the django
community you've a corns the most
performant and my bias is oats a hyper
colon has the most features but again
their features I'm here only I'm really
interested in so there we are but it
terms of these features there's support
for HTTP two and hyper corn and Daphne
you could do h-2b to WebSockets in hyper
corn which I don't figure you could do
elsewhere and in the server push and
HTTP WebSocket responses as well so
those are the features that I'm
interested in are you aski but most
people are actually more interested in
that kind of performance indeed fairly
ASCII frameworks and the async
frameworks in general this has been one
of the kind of most exciting things it
seems for the community so as you say a
little about that if we look at the last
tech in power at least I think this is
the last second pair if we look at the
top ten Python ones six of those are
ascii-based indeed the top two are s key
to more async and it's only tornado and
bottle whiskey so I think a skis made
quite a quite a name for itself here and
whisky as well so hopefully you've got a
very good idea about what a ski is and
hopefully I've convinced you it's the
right standard for the community to
adopt I think I might have time for
questions
[Applause]
so if you have anything to ask him
I was just wondering with this new
system because I'm used to flasks but I
never use any of this are we able to use
less JavaScript now because you know we
let the interaction that we have to
build with JavaScript with things going
back and forth you know with the
reactive applications is it possible to
do some of this stuff on the server now
like I'm thinking like what live view is
doing with Alex so I'm not quite sure
that this but maybe if if there's a if
there was an issue of WebSockets which
was easier to do in JavaScript yeah it's
quite easy to do in in Python now so
that might mean less JavaScript for you
okay any more questions
have you heard anything from Sanok about
implementing SGI three I guess would be
the right question today yeah so they've
been working on it I'm told today from
Tom who I can't see that hi Tom
but they're actually quite close so I
think there'll be a key framework and
maybe an ASCII service ooh any more
questions
so that was a very interesting overview
thank you very much what what do you
think still needs kind of work where are
the areas of the ascii spec or the
implementations that are most in need of
most of a need of improvement at the
moment I think it's actually had quite a
bit of development now so I think it's
in quite a good shape then there's
nothing nothing that brings to my mind I
was speaking to Tom about it earlier I
don't think this outfit this brings to
his mind either so I think it's a very
good shape now any other questions okay
okay once another question silly
question and do I detect the influence
of Swift on security in your naming of
your ASCII server hyper corn no I
actually know what I saw a pond that
wasn't there so so it's I used the hyper
sans i/o libraries mostly for it and
then I've tried to keep the interface as
similar as I can to jewnicorn so that's
where the name comes from interesting so
with this this wouldn't be a drop-in
replacement it you need a new framework
so let's say my particular stack nginx
USG - it would be a new framework and
ascii and then nginx is HTTP - so that
would be a tip that could be a
production stack yeah I think this is
more an issue we're trying to build
synchronous and asynchronous code
together I don't think it's really
possible so I think you have to choose
to be a sync
yeah so that was my name with quartz or
quartz the flask API we implemented with
async/await so to make it easier but
most of them are very similar to flash
so if you were to move to say Starla it
would be quite a pleasant and easy
experience for you we have time for one
more question maybe
hey I have a very simple question so
when it comes to the whe I suspect it's
very easy to remember pepp triple three
and quadruple three what is there a
pepper a SGI there isn't this bid talk
about writing one I do I don't think
it's progressed much recently but I kind
of I hope it will become a pet but wish
you'll see you can just search for it as
a ski or a skier if and you should find
it there's a I figure you should see you
can also take that link if you'd like
anything else we'll have one more minute
yep if I speak at a nice warm applause
please
[Applause]
you